all right the much-awaited
much-anticipated very very exciting
moment of the week for many people and
also something that some people can't
stand it's time for hatred mail
we're so all right it's wrong patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom all right it's been a little
while since we had a straight-up
anti-feminist sort of men's rights
activist esque
patriot mail and that's exactly what
we've got this week let's take a listen
to it together and see if we can make
heads or tails out of it yeah ah Pakman
you're miss and rest' feminist agenda is
showing you can't seem to accept there
are differences between men and women
this ping me too anti male agenda has
hijacked the liberal wing and it's
sickening
so basically get over at you ball s
wonder David Pakman is a paid actor for
the New World Order agenda he's been
exposed David Pakman hates America
confirmed so anytime you hear my name in
reverb like that for people who aren't
reading the transcript that's when my
name is in triple parentheses which is
the calling card of the anti-semitic
white nationalist types that's how they
identified Jewish individuals on the
internet by putting triple parentheses
in the way we're interpreting that for
hatred mail purposes is with a with a
sort of extraordinary reverb thing yeah
this is a listen number one the idea
that the David Pakman show is known for
a feminist agenda this is sort of like
with the Islam thing where we
simultaneously take Heat because I'm too
tough on Islam and also an apologist for
Islamic terror and the truth is that I
just call it like I see it and sometimes
I have one view on a particular
situation and sometimes another it's the
same thing with the feminist stuff right
like we did a piece long-form piece
about a gender pay gap and I pointed out
that a gender pay gap exists the 77
cents on the dollar is just flat-out
wrong it appears to be more like now
one or so cents on the dollar and some
element of that nine cent difference
certainly would be due to discrimination
against women some part of that nine
cent difference the people who believe
there's no pay gap whatsoever said I'm a
you know feminist soy boy whatever and
I've been totally subjugated by the
feminist agenda and then the some of the
people on the feminist side said David
how dare you question that it's 77 cents
on the dollar it you're both wrong
it's just there is a pay gap some part
of it is due to discrimination against
women and it's about 91 cents on the
dollar I would think that that long form
piece would just please everyone right
who knows there's no sound like both
sides win we meet on the middle we got
to the bottom of it and the truth wins
out rarely in politics is the truth
actually just in the middle of the two
extremes in this case the idea that
there's no pay gap whatsoever and that
it's 70 cents 77 cents on the dollar it
happened to be roughly in the middle and
everybody was still furious anyway this
is not a Miz and restore Miss Andrus
show a period and if that's that's how
you see it is because that's what you
want to see make 22 hey tree its cry by
using the coupon code hey tree at 40
when you sign up for membership at WWN
pokémon com coupon code hey tree at 40
gets you a 40% discount and it gets 22
hey tree its to shed it's here and and
it's a big fu to the hey treats does
that number grow every week it doesn't
noticing that it goes up by one one or
two every single week